هذه التطورات على الارض تتزامن اليوم مع
تصريحات امريكيه بشان قدرات حركه حماس حيث
قال جون كيري منسق السياسات الاستراتيجيه
في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي ان واشنطن
لا تؤمن بان الهجوم العسكري سيقضي على فكر
حماس وتتقبل فكره ان حماس ستظل موجوده
واوضح كيربي ان حماس لا تزال لديها قدرات
كبيره في قطاع
غزه
معنا من البيت الابيض مراسله الجزيره وجد
وقفي وجد اذا تقييم تابعناه من خلال ما
قاله جون كيربي في مداخلته قبل قليل اولا
ل طبيعه الحرب الحاليه في غزه والاهداف
المعلنه لهذه الحرف في ما يتعلق بالقضاء
على حماس ما اهم ما جاء في
كلامه ربما تصريحه بشكل واضح وللعلم للمره
الاولى ونحن الان على بعد نحو ثلاثه اشهر
من العمليات العسكريه والحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه اقرار البيت الابيض
على لسان جون كيربي بانه ما زالت لدى حماس
قدرات كبيره وقوه كبيره داخل قطاع غزه هذا
التصريح هو للمره الاولى واكد جون كيربي
بان هذا التصريح ياتي بعد اجراء الاداره
الامريكيه تقييما لمدى قدره او قوه حماس
العسكريه داخل قطاع غزه قد يفاجئ هذا
التصريح الواضح والصريح من قبل البيت
الابيض الكثيرين ولكن العمليات الموجوده
على الارض هي كانت تشير الى هذا الاتجاه
كل هذه الاسابيع والاشهر حتى اللحظه لم
تقدم اسرائيل اسما لقاده او لقائد واحد من
قاده حماس فتوجهت
وبحسب بعض المصادر توجهت
بضرب العاروري في بيروت البيت الابيض اكد
بانه لا توجد لديه ايه معلومات تشير الى
ضلوع اسرائيل بعمليه اغتيال صالح العاروري
ولكنه لدى سؤاله ما اذا كانت الاداره
الامريكيه تريد تقييم الجهه التي اغتالت
العاروري تقييم تحقيق اي شيء من هذا
القبيل اكد بان الاداره الامريكيه لن تجري
اي تقيييم بشان من هي الجهه المسؤوله عن
اغتيال العاروري واكد بان لا علاقه
للاداره الامريكيه بعمليه اغتيال صالح
العاروري طبعا
عدم التاكيد بشكل قاطع بهذه الطريقه من
قبل البيت الابيض بانه لن يجري اي تقييم
او تحقيق امر مستغرب لم نعتاده عاده البيت
الابيض الولايات المتحده تمد يد العون
التي للدول التي تشهد احداثا قد تتطلب
تحقيقات دقيقه وما الى ذلك لا نعلم ما اذا
لبنان طلب من اي جهه المساهمه في التحقيق
بشه بشان الجهه الضالع ولكن المؤكد
بالنسبه لبيت الابيض انه لن يساهم بتحقيق
او بتقييم بحسب قول جون كيربي بشان ما حدث
في لبنا
وجده وقفي من البيت الابيض شكرا جزيلا
لك